but i guess um  one of the reasons would be that with  the government you have surrogate  decision makers and they cannot possibly  know as much as the individuals whose  personal decisions have been preempted  um something that i just was in  discussion with with like friends and  family during this last election or  electing voting people into the office  and all that good stuff was how can  someone make a law for  like low-income people when they don't  understand what it is to be in that  situation and if you don't know the  situation you can empathize with someone  but you're not going to physically  understand what it is to be in a certain  situation whatever it is you may  emotionally understand what it is to be  in like a harsh situation but mentally  and physically if you've never been in  it you're never going to fully  understand it